hello everyone and welcome to the
International candidate super tournament
in Surrey of 1953 this is a game played
between Miguel Knight orphan Samuel
Reshevsky branched and has a lot to say
about this game and he really scolds
night or how he treated the position as
the position that arises in this game is
one of the most known positions there
were in the names of Indian defense and
well he's simply extremely displeased
with night off but let's see the game
this is also a game from round one and
night off goes d4 Reshevsky goes Knight
to f6
we have c4 e6 Knight to c3 and Bishop to
b4 the nimzo-indian defense and here
branch Tang says that at the time this
game was played in 1953 nimza which
probably never even dreamed that even
thirty thirty years after he invented
this defense that the world's top
grandmasters had no idea if if if a3 was
a good move for white here to
immediately force the bishop to either
capture the knight or go back to e7 but
okay III was played
we have c5 and this is another good
example that Bronstein gives when
nimzowitsch developed his defense his
idea was never to push c5 immediately
his idea was to exchange this knight on
c3 and after B captures somehow provoke
White's to push d5 and then create a
very nice outpost for his knight on c5
but in 1953 the main idea was to battle
the center immediately so c5 Bishop to
d3 we have castles Knight to f3 and d5
neither of castles Knight to c6 and we
have a three now Bishop captures and c3b
captures on c3 and D captures on c4
Bishop captures on c4 and Queen to c7
and this is the position branch 10 says
that this position was analyzed as much
as for example the Evans gambit a
hundred years ago 100 years ago from the
time this game was played
and well there are a lot of options for
white here and a lot of options have
been tried in this position because this
was a well frequently played position
and in this position
neither plays a four and this is the
move that Bronstein disapproves of an
eye drops idea is he wants to he must
develop this dark square Bishop appears
on c1 which is really buried in the
position with Bishop to a3 and somehow
we get a hold of this strong diagonal
here but this will not go as planned
better idea Braunstein says would be to
somehow push efore and E 5 kick away the
night from f6 then you're free to
develop the bishop on this diagonal and
go for some sort of a King side attack
and blacks plan is to after white
decides to push the e4 pawn this central
structure will be somewhat weakened and
then black should attack it but the move
neither neither of jerseys is a4 and
we'll see how that went
b6 as of course were chefs he's
expecting Bishop to a3 which Knight of
does play Bishop to a3 we have Bishop to
b7 Bishop to e2 rook F to d8 and Queen
to c2 Knights do it Knight to a5 by
reshef ski with a with a brilliant idea
actually
and I'd replace D captures on c5 b
captures on c5 and c4
it seems that neither of has solved the
problem of his dark square bishop and
now he pushes c4 and he's ready to play
Bishop to b2 to assume this also very
strong diagonal but the problem is
reshef ski plays Bishop to e4 what a
temple on the Queen we have Queen to c3
and now rook a to b 8 and now my Reshef
ski is controlling the B file this
bishop is also controlling the b1 square
so neither can never place and it works
on b1 and any moves like Bishop to b2
now would be pretty silly after the rook
comes to be 3 for example
so after located to b8 another place
rook F to D 1 he wants to exchange a1
rook so
rook captures and we have Bishop to c6
and Reshevsky plan is clear here this a
for pawn that neither pushed in that
thoroughly analyzed position will now
become a permanent target and the blacks
plan is very clear here he will do
anything he can to get a hold of this a4
pawn he wants to create a passed pawn of
his own and simply push it to victory
so Queen to c2 defending the pawn we
have h6 not allowing any Knight g5 ideas
h3 also not allowing Knight g4 ideas now
Knight to b3 blocking the Queen's
protection of the e4 pawn and Bishop to
b2 now here we have nice Knight to d7
not allowing Bishop captures on f6 to
destroy the King's defenses Queen to c3
and I drove is now threatening checkmate
on g7 this is prevented with f6 and here
well both players were low on time and
the knight of tries one more move to
trick reshef ski he plays a knight to
aged 92 h2 with the idea of Knight to g4
and well Knight second he would like to
sacrifice the knight on f6 if reshef ski
ever decides to play Knight to b6 and go
for that a4 pawn so Reshevsky played
nice to b6 and in this position
Reshevsky had a less than 4 minutes on
the clock and he offered in either of a
draw which night of happily accepted but
branchnet says that this is perfectly
played by black and black has a
strategically won game
black can't save this pawn and well you
don't you can't really capture the
nighttime be free if you play something
like Queen captures on b3 then Knight
captures on a for opening up a
discovered attack on your queen and also
this Knight is now attacking the bishop
when the Queen moves rook captures
Bishop and this is winning for black D a
pawn will be simply too powerful
so Reshevsky did everything right here
spend a bit too much time to to create
such a such a correct game but it's it's
definitely again again with the study
and and when you see a move like a for
to learn that it's a positional mistake
and how to take advantage of it so yeah
I hope you don't mind that I chose a
game that ended in a draw
although it it's it's like a victory I
mean if he had more time he would
continue to play this and win the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and I do hope you
enjoyed this branchline series so far I
would like to thank John Anthony tables
and of course Tony Moore guitar for
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
to really appreciate it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
[Music]